they barely made it out alive
a galloping wildfire trapped more than
200 people
at a remote campground in the rugged
central california mountains
when fire blocked the only road out the
california national guard mounted an
emergency
nighttime rescue mission sending in
helicopters to airlift the campers to
safety
this picture shows dozens of evacuees
crowded
into a national guard chinook helicopter
that fire grew so quickly so fast it
trapped people
at mammoth pools reservoir up in the
mountains
the creek fire broke out on friday
evening and quickly
exploded in size by sunday it had burned
more than
18 thousand hectares tinder dry
forest and underbrush fed the flames
several small communities in the area
were evacuated
as hundreds of firefighters battled the
blaze
authorities say 63 people were hurt
fleeing the flames
17 were admitted to local hospitals
injuries including
broken bones lacerations scrapes bruises
those kind of things
another blaze called the el dorado fire
is threatening homes near
san bernardino east of los angeles
it broke out on saturday and grew
rapidly burning more than 1200 hectares
and forcing some residents to evacuate
the multiple fires are burning as a
record-smashing heat wave
scorches california and other western
states
a community near los angeles recorded a
blistering
49.4 degrees celsius
rob reynolds al jazeera los angeles